we're up there
just about the time that the polar night
occurs
so that means it's going to be dark
essentially 24 hours a day the sun never
gets above the mountain
uh peaks so the light levels are
extremely low
and you're in a boat in these little
coves or
you know at the edges of fjords it's
cold it's dark it might be snowing
brian scary has been an underwater
photographer and explorer here at
national geographic
for more than two decades and then when
i think the time is right
i take a deep breath and i slide
underwater
he's on a mission to see a pot of killer
whales off the coast of norway
also known as orcas these are some of
the largest most powerful predators in
the ocean
they hunt everything from humpback
whales and sea lions
to squid and salmon even tiny herring
it should be said that there are no
reports of orcis killing humans in the
wild
but these are school bus sized creatures
and brian wants to get up close
like uncomfortably close so you're
kicking really hard
to get down those first few feet those
first few meters
and then as the suit compresses you
start to sink like a stone and it might
be
a couple thousand feet deep below you so
you you've got all of that on your mind
but here are these orcas
they all of a sudden just sort of
materialize out of the green
haze in the background
they are intimidating animals orca
in my estimation are arguably the the
most intelligent animal
in the ocean and are capable of
of just about anything they're they're
scary smart
they are 30 plus feet in length and they
have this massive bulk
and they have teeth and they are super
geniuses
so they could mess you up if they wanted
to
i'm trying desperately to control my
heartbeat because they can sense that
they they pick up their acoustic animals
they're very tuned to those things so
if i seem nervous or threatening or
agitated they might not come near me so
i'm i'm
trying to think of anything i'm thinking
of home i'm thinking of
you know a big cheeseburger i'm thinking
of anything that's gonna
calm me down orcas
are freakishly smart they're actually
members of the dolphin family
and scientists have identified that they
live in groups with their own
distinctive cultures and dialects
so they're curious about what brian this
weird rubber suited animal
is doing in their water some adult orcas
in a calf emerge from the darkness
i remember the the adults being a little
standoffish they slowed down and they
sort of checked me out
but the calf broke away from the adults
and he came around and started doing
these donuts around me did these big
circles he was just
his tail was moving a mile a minute and
he was just doing circles around me he
maybe never saw
a human underwater before i'm peter guin
editor-at-large at national geographic
magazine and this is overheard
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at natgeo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
over the last three years brian scary
has traveled throughout the world's
oceans
photographing the complex world of
whales for the magazine
and working with a team of filmmakers to
shoot the secrets of the whales
a disney plus original series from
national geographic
in this special earth day episode he'll
introduce us to some of the different
orca families he encountered in the
waters around norway and new
zealand and how in many ways these sea
monsters turned out to be more like
us than you might think
[Music]
more after the break
you gotta tell me the cadillac story
the cadillac story the infamous cadillac
story yeah well
to understand how brian ends up nose to
nose with orcas
you need to hear the cadillac story i
actually overheard brian tell this to a
group of other photographers once
it's kind of like his origin story he
grew up in a little textile mill town
in massachusetts far away from the coast
so
if he wanted to go diving he had to get
creative
so there were these stone quarries in
his town that were flooded with water
and that's where brian would dive they
were
sort of dark and spooky and deep
maybe 100 plus feet deep people would
throw
cars into those quarries i think many of
these were stolen cars
and you could easily get entangled in in
all of these piles of cars down there if
you
you know god forbid swim inside uh the
front seat of a
of a car that was upside down in 90 feet
of black water
um you know you could get hung up in
there and and
you really had to keep your wits about
you and figure things out
brian says that by the time he was in
college he realized that there was a
semi-lucrative business to be had by
going down and taking parts off these
cars
and selling them to anybody that needed
a new set of tires or you know a 1976
corvette hood or the rear view mirror
off of mercury something like that
i would go diving in these quarries i
would in the wintertime
go out with a friend of mine with an axe
and chop through the ice or use a
chainsaw
sometimes the ice was two feet thick and
then with our wetsuits we
would you know slip into the water using
lines and go down
80 or 90 feet and uh with a tire iron
you know take uh
take some tires off okay so on one of
those dives
he has the jackpot a brand new white
cadillac
it's upside down in about 100 feet of
black water
but it's got this fancy set of spoke
room wheels
and brian knows these things go for like
1500 bucks
and i have to just you know for context
say that
this this town that i was living in it
was uh
it was populated in those days largely
by italian
americans and irish americans i'm of
irish descent
and um so a lot of my family lived in
that area
but my dive buddy at the time was
convinced that
a brand new cadillac that was sitting
upside down in a quarry
had to be organized crime and he was
sure that if we opened that trunk
you know upside down popped it open with
this pry bar
that a body was going to come tumbling
out so he was
he was not into this at all but i needed
to dive
yeah exactly it's like the scene with
joe pesci
at night going to have dinner with his
mother at like two in the morning
on the guys in the trunk
so brian dived down he tried to get the
wheels off the cadillac
but they've got these special wheel
locks to keep people from stealing them
so he has to go back and do a little
research he finds out that there's a
special little key in the trunk
that will unlock the wheels but the
trunk is also locked
so he gets a pry bar and dives back down
into the pitch black water
and with mafia stories running through
his head he jams the pry bar into the
trunk
and tries to muscle it open sure enough
i got it open and
nobody rolled out and i kind of swam in
upside down
and stuck behind the spare tire was a
tire iron
so i pulled it out and like i was told
there was this little cable wrapped
around it with this
perfect key to unlock the locking lug so
i stuck it in a socket wrench and a big
breaker bar or whatever and
i went out and i spun off those four
tires and
i sold them for maybe a couple hundred
dollars and
the guy got a 1500 set of wheels and i
got a couple hundred bucks and
we didn't have to bury any dead bodies
so you know it was all
it's all good it was all good no fbi
investigation to follow
this condition no exactly
[Music]
so that's one way to get your start is a
marine photographer
underwater repo man after that brian
takes just about any diving gig he can
get
and explores all kinds of shipwrecks and
sunken german u-boats in the north
atlantic
and finally he becomes one of national
geographic's go-to underwater
photographers
since then he's observed a litany of
fascinating creatures in the ocean
but orcas are a breed apart for his
recent project he spent time in norway
photographing families of orca working
together they corral schools of herring
into these dense clusters called bait
balls
i was free diving down maybe 20 30 feet
in that very cold water i've got a thick
wetsuit on a free diving wetsuit
a lot of weight um trying to control my
heartbeat i'm diving down
and here is this orca that is
almost like a a sheepdog he's hurting
those those herring the herring have a
bluish
tinge to them the water is dark green
around them the black and white whale
is is making this this this slice
almost through the outer edges of the
bait ball it's it's deforming the the
bait ball
and they're pushing them to to aggregate
them as tightly as possible
and what we don't see in a picture like
it like this
is that there will be several other orca
on the opposite side of that bait ball
doing the same thing they're closing
ranks
and they're corralling them and then
they will swim through and stun them
with their tail
and then go through and pick them off
what do you hear when you're under water
like that or can you hear what
what's this the audio world down down
there like
it can be very vocal um these are
animals that
have to communicate to do these feeding
strategies in this location in fact as
that polar night emerges and it's dark
all the time
they can no longer rely on just
sight or visual cues and they have to
communicate
so you hear these clicks and whistles
and
cacophony of sounds that are all around
you and again
you know for me it's this frenzy of of
activity it's it's this
three-dimensional
bait ball of of silver fish that are
terrified and they're they're they're
pulsing
in tightly together and then expanding i
look down
below my fins uh into the darkness
and i see white flashes of orca
i can hear them i see their teeth as
they're they're
sort of smiling as they come around the
edges of the of the bait ball
and and i'm you know desperately trying
to frame a shot i'm looking through my
viewfinder and i'm spinning around in
in 360 on every access i'm looking up
and down and around and over my shoulder
and
my neck is is you know is stiff because
i'm constantly spinning around
brian is free diving meaning no scuba
gear
he's holding his breath but he can't get
deep enough to get a good shot
so he resurfaces and grabs his air tanks
but there's a problem scuba gear is
noisy
whales are very uh acoustic animals they
are tuned in to sound
so if there's this big clunky thing down
there
blowing bubbles and the sound of the
regulator is probably something they can
pick up on you're unlikely to get close
to them
the moment i switched from freediving to
scuba
the orca attitude changed the minute i
got down there
it was like being scanned by a super
computer they
they just came up and i felt that they
were reading
everything about me they they knew what
i had for dinner last night
they didn't threaten me they didn't
touch me they didn't you know bare their
teeth or
anything overly threatening but i just
felt this sense
that look buddy those fish are mine
so you know if if you want to watch
that's okay
but make no mistake about it
one thing about orcas they live in all
the planet's oceans
in frigid arctic and antarctic waters to
warmer subtropical and tropical regions
and orcas in different places eat
different foods just like some humans
like
spicy indian cuisine and others prefer
hamburgers
orcas have their own favorites too and
for each of these foods
orca have figured out unique hunting
strategies to catch their prey
orca have this preference for
international
cuisine they like ethnic foods the orca
in
patagonia have a taste for
sea lion pups and only a couple of
families
of orca in the world that live in that
area have figured out how to come up on
a beach and eat
those little sea lions in norway as we
discussed
they like herring so they figured out
how to feed on herring
brian made a trip to photograph the orca
around new zealand
and he discovered they've got a taste
for a special delicacy
the orcas that live in new zealand
have figured out a strategy for their
favorite food which is stingrays and
they
will move into these shallow mangroves
and harbors
and very deftly pick up a stingray they
actually turn it upside down
and essentially put it to sleep and
something called tonic
immobility which works with some species
of sharks and rays if you
sort of turn them upside down they go
immobile and then they can eat more
easily i guess
predate on them they can eat them and
during one dive
brian looks up from his camera and sees
a giant orca swimming right at him
she has a stingray in her mouth it's one
of those moments that
wow if i can get this if i can get a
picture um
it's going to be extraordinary as she's
nearing me she drops the stingray sort
of like in front of me and then she just
keeps swimming
and i kneel a few feet away from the
dead stingray
laying in the sand now and i'm hoping
maybe
that she will come back out of the
corner of my
eye my right eye i see
this giant bulk of a whale
slowly moving in and i'm just staying
perfectly still i'm not moving i don't
want to be threatening i'm just
sort of hunkered down there on my knees
holding my camera with two hands
and i see her go behind me i lose track
of her she
circles around back and then a second
later she emerges
on my left side and i see her in my left
eye she comes around
and stops directly in front of me she's
now
facing me with the stingray between us
so here we are in about 30 or 35 feet of
water i mean if she stood on her head
she her tail would have been out of the
water she's that big wow but she's
she looks at me and then looks at the
ray
looks at me looks at the ray does this
several times as if to say
are you going to eat that you know i i i
dropped it there for you
and then when clearly i'm not going to
do that
she just very gently bends over kind of
almost inverts her body vertically
and picks the ray up and then slowly
just
raises her head and now she's you know
four or five feet in front of me with
this ray dangling from her mouth
that's partially eaten and i
shoot a couple of frames and then she
gently turns around and i see another
orca come over
and they begin to food share that's what
they do they one will hold it the other
will come in and rip off a piece and
they
they feed but do you think she was doing
that to you that she was holding it in
her mouth so you might come up and take
a bite
you know i maybe i i don't know i mean
it's very possible i mean i you know
who knows what they're really thinking
and i don't want to over
you know anthropomorphize the animals
but yet
we know that they're very smart we know
they have culture we know that they food
share
we know that she was you know doing this
behavior right in front of me holding
that ray
um maybe she was you know maybe i should
have taken my regulator i was using a
scuba tank on that
uh and and swam over and took a chunk
out to you know just to be polite
but um in any case very rude human brian
i was it was it's like that scene
indiana jones where she
the the woman he's with doesn't want to
eat the uh chilled monkey brains or
something
yeah anyway
but being picky about their food isn't
the only behavior that makes orcas seem
closer to humans
brian was shooting off the coast of
norway during thanksgiving
and he was really missing his family
when he came across an orca family
it was an encounter that made him feel
like there's so much more to learn about
these intelligent creatures
it was one of these another one of these
snowy cold dark days
i've got my suit on we're out on the on
the ocean
and we come across a family of orca
that seems to be moving very
in a very determined fashion they're
just sort of porpoising they're sort of
swimming
in a a very purposeful way
i get in the water a couple of times and
get a glimpse and they just
they they have no interest in me they're
just kind of moving very quickly
and eventually after a few jumps after a
few dives
i noticed that one of them an adult
female
is carrying a dead calf a dead baby
[Music]
i had seen this twice before with pilot
whales where
i i saw them having this what i call
funeral procession it was it was this
morning ceremony
it was most likely the mother her calf
had died
and she had it draped over the front
part of her head
and she was swimming with this dead calf
through the water some scientists think
this may have been a kind of mourning
though others are quick to point out
there could be other explanations
we still don't fully understand this
behavior but some other whale species
appear to do it too
in any case it had a powerful effect on
brian
i remember feeling like an intruder i
i didn't want to overly intrude
and it was something that was i i was
not
supposed to be part of um but yet i did
hope to get a picture i wasn't going to
press it too hard and i did
after several attempts i did have one
moment where i was close enough to make
a frame
very grainy sort of frame but but
you know it was
a mixed set of emotions i mean here it
was thanksgiving i was thinking about my
family back home
and about missing thanksgiving dinner
and here's this family of orca
in the cold norwegian arctic um
mourning the loss of a new member of
their family
scientists estimate there are roughly 50
000 orcas left in the oceans
but populations in several areas are
endangered
one of the biggest threats is food
shortages due to overfishing habitat
destruction and diseases spread by large
commercial fish farms
the other is chemical pollution tons of
chemicals end up in the oceans
and over time they accumulate in the
fatty tissue of marine animals
especially those at the top of the food
chain including orcas
these issues and others have given an
urgency to brine's work
these animals have identity they have
personality they have traditions they
they have language and food preferences
and singing competitions and they have
empathy
they care about each other they
celebrate each other
and and my hope is that that becomes a
game changer
that that we begin to see ourselves
not so different than the natural world
and and maybe
that helps us protect it wow man well
said
so there's one question that national
geographic photographers always get
it's about their closest call you've
just listed off like
i think probably several of my greatest
nightmares
i mean i got to ask you people will want
to know you know is there one
event that was sort of the most scary
most
you know tentative you know in terms of
like your survival
you know there's a handful that that
come up and and i should preface this
but there's one
that he still thinks about in 2004 brian
was working on a story in ireland
he and his assistant came up from a dive
planning to get back on their boat
no problem right but then it wasn't
there
and there was a very swift current that
was sweeping us out to sea
the dive boat was that they were a great
crew really really great captain and
crew
however there was a big atlantic swell
that day
the sun was at our back so they couldn't
see us and they had the engines running
they had a new deckhand on the boat that
day
so when we were shouting to try to get
their attention
he couldn't hear us so they began
you know sort of a search operation and
we were just getting swept out to sea
and the only thing
sticking above the surface is our head
and shoulders
so i was holding on to the a d-ring on
the weight belt of my buddy sean because
i knew we would eventually drift apart
otherwise and that would have made
things even worse
so you know you're drifting and you're
drifting in and you go through this
range of emotions in the beginning it's
it's sort of funny
it's kind of like oh look those guys
they're they're looking over there and
here we are over here i can't believe
they can't find us and then you get
angry okay so now they're just little
blips on the surface out there on the
horizon
you know and they can see the
helicopters and boats searching for them
but an hour passes and then two
nobody's found them and then you start
to
resign yourself to well what if i don't
get found what what if what if this is
it
and you just want to desperately climb
up on a rock and wave your arms and legs
and hands and scream
but you can't you're helpless you know
i'm in a dry suit holding my underwater
housing and just drifting
brian and his wife had just had a new
baby and he's thinking about the two of
them back home all alone
and meanwhile a fisherman has taken some
tourists out on his boat
to see the islands nearby he had a group
of elderly ladies on the boat
tourists that were sitting on these
little wooden benches on the back deck
of his old wooden boat
the fisherman turns on his radio and he
hears about divers
lost or dead at sea and so he starts
looking around
and guess what he found him so when he
finally came
upon us he reached into his anchor
locker and pulled out an old
rope ladder he told me later that he
thought it would disintegrate he'd never
used it for decades but
he threw it over the side my assistant
went up first and then i climbed up and
i've got my dry suit and my hood and my
big thick mitts and you know i look like
some sea monster
but this was my um this was my james
bond moment because all these ladies
had their cameras you know to their eye
ready to take a picture of me
so i pulled off my mitts and then i
pulled off my hood and i just said
scary brian's scary and reached out to
shake their hands
i i was shaken and stirred inside but
but i had enough presence of mind to
uh to capitalize on the moment
and if you want to know more about scary
brian's scary
we have an article for you where he goes
into detail about his 12
000 hours underwater an orchestra just
part of brian's multi-year whale project
to learn more about the fascinating
worlds of several species
including belugas humpbacks and sperm
whales
check out his cover story on whale
culture in the may issue of national
geographic
all four episodes of the disney plus
original series
secrets of the whales from national
geographic streams earth day
april 22nd on disney plus we've also
published a book of brian's amazing
photos called
secrets of the whales that's all in the
show notes right there in your podcast
app
overheard at national geographic is
produced by alana strauss
brian gutierrez jacob pinter laura sim
and carla wills our senior editor is eli
chen
our executive producer of audio is davar
ardalan our fact checkers are julie beer
and robin palmer
our copy editor is amy kolzak our
episode was sound design and engineered
by ted woods
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
the national geographic society
committed to eliminating and protecting
the wonder of our world
funds the work of national geographic
explorer and photographer brian scary
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic
editorial director and i'm your host
peter gwyn
thanks for listening see y'all soon
[Music]
you